summer summer Sunderland summer lattice
yeah how do you know that over here
because we've done research on my summer
land was the first TV show I was I can't
believe talk about the summer land was
the first show I ever was on and it was
your first it was my first onscreen kiss
I think it was like 16 so I was very
nervous and yes I still get nervous but
I was very nervous for this day yeah
it's all about making I wanted to make
her as comfortable as possible she was
17 and went in to go in for the kiss and
everyone's watching it's a closed set
even more awkward yeah like only special
people can watch yeah and everyone else
is on whatever her name was
poor Kay Panabaker Oh
very diverse the names of the chimp
Seaworth will
[Applause]
why poor her bill already I at lunch
they serve fish and I was I'm not you
know the the lunch spreads on set some
it can or any sense you've never seen
food like this I was like 17 I've never
seen like crab legs up for multiple
people movies right I've never seen it
was a catered lunch and my mom was
freaking out we've never seen this much
food it was insane so I just went to
town and I started eating I was doing
only guest spotting so I had crab it's a
man I had all this stuff and next was
the kissing scene and I was very nervous
and we went in for the kiss I got off
this close and all the sudden I yeah I
shut my eyes and I'm ready to go and
nothing happens I'm going further and
it's nothing's happening further like
thinking eventually we're gonna touch
and all of a sudden here oh my gosh did
you have sanded for lunch yeah and it
ruined ruined Oh first guess sorry I
promise I brush my teeth I learned a big
lesson that day you do carry a
toothbrush with you everywhere you go I
just had one whom I really just had one
back actually you know what I don't know
a full one but if anybody wants it
hope springs eternal what's in his teeth
sometimes sometimes kissing's okay
though
[Music]
you